حيث استشهد شاب فلسطيني بعد ان نطق
مستوطنون وجنود اسرائيل هناون الرصاصه
عليه بذريعه محاولته طعنه احد المستوطنين
في موقع قرب قريه راس كركر غربيه رام الله
قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي شاب حاول
مهاجمه احد المستوطنين بمفك داخل ما
وصفتها بمزرعه وانه تم اطلاق الرصاص عليه
وقتله قبل ان ينفذهما على حد تعبيرها
تم تصفيه المهاجم دون ان يصاب احد من
المستوطنين والجنود باذن
في جنين اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
فجر اليوم جريحا من بلده عجه واقتحمت عده
قرى في المنطقه كمشنات حملتها تنشيط واسعه
فيها
لؤي بشير غربيه الذي اصيب برصاص قبل ايام
بعد اقتحام البلده ودهمي منزل عائلته
العمري وليد شهيد ايضا غربيه رام الله
والمزيد من الاعتقالات ضعنا في الصوره
شهيد الجديد في الثانيه والاربعين من عمره
هو طارق معالي من قريه كفر نعمه قتله او
مستوطن على جبل الريسان الواقع بين قريتي
كفر نعمه وراس كلك الغربي مدينه رام الله
وذلك عندما اقترب من موقع حوله هذا
المستوطن واخرون الى مزرعه خاصه بهم بهذا
الشهيد ارتفع عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين منذ
بدايه العام الحالي الى 18 شهيدا نصفهم من
محافظه جنين وبينهم اربعه اطفال ملابسات
ما حدث في صباح اليوم همم تشير الى التالي
الروايه الفلسطينيه هي ان المواطن طارق
علي كان في سيارته التي تعطلت وعندما ترجع
على مقربه من هذه البؤره الاستيطانيه
هاجمه المستوطن وبعد ذلك اطلق عليه النار
روايه الجيش الاحتلال هي
المواطن الفلسطيني
وصل الى البؤره الاستيطانيه وهمم ترجل
منها وهو يحمل مفكا وهجم المستوطن الذي
قام باطلاق النار عليه وقتله ال- اللافته
في ذلك وانت باينت روايات انا المستوطنين
يتصرفون كانهم جيش كامل الصباحيات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه هذا ثاني مواطن منذ
بدايه العام الحالي الذي يقتله يقتله
مستوطن مسلح يستولي على ارض الفلسطينيه
قبل ذلك كان قرب الظاهريه جنوبيه مدينه
الخليل والذي ايضا الا وزراء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه المفرطه في تطرفها
عاده يباركون لهؤلاء المستوطنين قيامهم
باطلاق النيران وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
قالت بان النيران اطلقت عليه من قبل هذا
المستوطن وانها بلغت بانه طارق عوده يوسف
علي 42 عاما وواضح بانضمام المستوطنين
بمثل هذا الى جانب جيش الاحتلال هو مزيد
من التصعيد ودفع الامور الى نحو انفجار
محتبل في وقت قريب اذا تواصلت على هذا
الامور على هذا الحال شكرا جزيلا لك وليد
العمري مدير مكتبنا من رام الله